Hey Youtubers it's Charlie.This is going to be my Game of Thrones Episode 4 video.
Lots of exciting stuff to talk about.
I feel like the show did everything short of screaming in confirming one of the biggest fan theories from the books.
So we'll talk about that that stuff.
And new round of the giveaway starts now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video
Just careful for spoilers as we get started.
So this is gonna be Top 7 moments just because there was a whole lot of extra stuff in this episode.
Starting with #7 - Jorah is taking Tyrion to Daenerys.
This is right out of the books, so it wasn't a huge surprise.
The tease was in the previous episode so that he was taking him to the Queen.
Tyrion initially thought that it was his sister, but then he remembers who Jorah is
and that he had been informing Varys in the small council on Daenerys in the earlier seasons.
"Remind me how you were serving her inside a brothel"
Well when you think about it, if he'd been working for Varys the whole time and Varys had secretly been part of the Targaryen Restoration
Maybe in spying on Daenerys, he was inadvertently helping her or at least helping Varys make decisions based on where she was at.
That's just a theory.
If you take it in the literal context - yes, he was a traitor to her.
Initially, it's just that Robert was the one that was calling all the shots.
He's like, "I wanna spy on Daenerys right now. I want to murder her."
Varys, as Master of Whisperers, was responsible for hiring Jorah.
I know everyone is wondering where Varys is now.
We'll probably find out next week. He'll probably be back.
Onto #6 - Cersei reinstates the Faith Militant and they arrest Loras for being gay.
My favorite quote from the Cersei scenes this week: "There's a sinner in our very midst, shielded by gold and privilege."
She's was talking about Loras.
The double meaning and the kind of look in the High Sparrow's eyes are that Cersei is a sinner shielded by gold and privilege.
"May they all be judged justly"
Right now though, it's only gone as far as Loras.
And as we can see from Margaery being so pissed, Tommen isn't able to do shit about it.
They just want to put Tommen forward as an ineffectual leader.
He's a little boy so you can't be too mad at him.
The show aged him up quite a bit. He almost looks like a teenager.
In the books, he is way younger. He's still a toddler. He's like a pudgy little kid.
The downside is that last week when they had sex, that's probably going to be the last that you see that for a long time.
There's no way that Margaery is gonna give it up while Loras is still in chains.
For those that are wondering, he's actually being held at Baelor's Sept.
So, expect to see a trial-type situation, you know, and a twist of what happened to Tyrion last year.
He was put on trial and got steam rolled by the justice system.
Now, thanks to Cersei, there's a new law man in town.
And he's going to steam roll anyone he thinks is committing sin.
I'm kind of digging bad-ass Lancel too.
He is way better now than he was in Season 1.
That's the seven pointed star. That's the symbol of the church that they're carving into their foreheads.
Eventually, they're probably going to find out that Tommen is also the son of twinsest.
If you could hear in that background shot in the crowd shot when he went to the sept,
they were screaming "Bastard!" at him - he seemed a little confused like he didn't totally understand what was going on.
But that's going to come back. That's just like a hint of things to come.
Onto #5 - Jaime and Bronn arrive at Dorne
So just a reminder - what they're doing is they're trying to infiltrate the Water Gardens to get Myrcella out.
They just want to get her and come back to King's Landing.
Jaimie,unlike the Sand Snakes, doesn't want to start a war - like an all out war with Dorne.
That's why it's only the two of them.
Jaimie and Bronn are like the new Jaimie and Brienne.
Just absolute comedic relief.
Along with some really good action scenes.
They even gave a shout-out to Tarth as they were passing by.
Turns out it is not full of sapphires, as Jaimie said.
There is just a bunch of really good one-liner moments, but I love that Jaimie is now using his hand as a defensive device.
Although it was totally on accident.
And he wants to die in the arms of the woman he loves.
Yes, I do think he is talking about Brienne, even if he is not willing to admit it out loud.
I do think there's still a part of him that loves Cersei, just not in the way that he loved her in the past.
I think he feels more of an obligation to Cersei because she's family - because she's the mother of his children.
And he's gone into like full on dad-mode. "It has to be me. I have to be the one that rescues her."
So in addition to waiting for like an all-out Jaimie and Brienne love scene,
now we need to wait for a scene when Jaimie openly tells one of his children "I am your father."
Onto #4 - Meet the Sand Snakes
This is T-ing up the Arianne Martell plot from the books.
Starting a war with King's Landing.
Whether or not they're successful remains to be seen
because Doran Martell, as they said, wants to keep the peace.
He has his own plans though. You know, just because they say he wants peace doesn't mean that he isn't going to do anything about Oberyn's death.
For now though, we just have to wait for a potential meeting between Jaimie and Bronn and the Sand Snakes.
I'll add a link in the description for the Sand Snakes video I just did.
It just explains some of the differences between the show and the books.
This episode was really just the first introduction to them - so it's gonna be a few more episodes before we see what their characters are like on the show.
Onto #3 - Melisandre tries to make a shadow baby with Jon Snow
"There is great power in you. You resist it, that's your mistake.
Power to make light. Power to create shadows."
Don't you just wonder how powerful a Jon Snow's shadow baby would be.
There really is no benchmark for stuff like that.
You have to assume that the more powerful the blood, the more powerful whatever Melisandre conjurs up ends up being.
I guess it depends on how powerful you think Jon Snow's blood is versus Stannis.
That's an argument that'll have to wait until after like the final season.
For right now, the show is positioning both Stannis and Jon Snow as heroes.
That was what that whole Shireen scene with Stannis was about -
showing that he's a very caring person in his own cold way.
But all this Melisandre making sex eyes at Jon Snow is starting to make a little more sense
given the context of some of the other scenes that have to do with his parentage.
Onto #2 - The show officially starts pushing R + L= J
Some of you probably expected this to come at a certain point.
Some of you might have pooped your pants.
Some probably still don't believe it.
Just taking the show at it's word, assuming Littlefinger was not lying and Ser Barriston Selmy is not lying
and I definitely don't think he was lying - they're trying to position Rhaegar Targaryen as a nice person
who was in love with Lyanna Stark.
"How many tens of thousands had to die because he chose your aunt."
The crown of roses blue as frost also ties in with the really big prophecy with the show.
Rhaegar Targaryen was obsessive about the prophecy - the prince who was promised.
That's why everyone thinks that that is Jon Snow.
He's like the secret prince that was promised.
It's just that the prophecy describes a blue rose growing in a wall of ice.
So you have Jon Snow, the blue rose, that was born of Lyanna Stark
up at a wall of ice, you know as in "The Wall" literally.
Dan and Dave aren't really big on doing prophecies on the TV show.
They did kind of do Maggie the Frog, which is a prophecy, but I don't think they're going to get too crazy with that stuff in the future.
Hopefully we'll just start to see more clues, like more characters, start to point evidence at the R+L= J theory.
As for right now, the best evidence is what Ser Barriston Selmy said and what Littlefinger said.
But the tourney at Harrenhal is a really famous event.
Rhaegar Targaryen, really great jouster, won the tournament
crowned Lyanna Stark instead of his wife, Elia Martell, Doran and Oberyn's sister
causing everyone to lose their shit
including Robert Bartheon, who Lyanna Stark was promised to.
And just to reiterate, Robert's Rebellion didn't start because Rhaegar Targaryen obsconded with Lyanna Stark.
It started because the Mad King was executing a bunch of nobles and their sons.
But onto my #1 WTF moment - Grey Worm and Barriston Selmy look like they're dead
The Sons of the Harpy lay a trap for the Unsullied and Grey Worm and Barriston Selmy kind of get caught up in it.
Ever since that moment when Barriston Selmy left King's Landing and said "I could cut through all of you like a carving knife through a cake,"
they had to show off some of his skills.
He's a really old person, so if he's this good now, imagine how good he was in his prime.
I also saw a lot of you guys complaining on Twitter that Grey Worm seemed like he went down too easy.
They just - they want you to wonder whether or not they're going to survive.
There is a promo for next week's episode. Just because it's kind of spoilery, it kind of answers some of those questions, I won't talk about it here.
But if you guys have seen it, just use spoiler tags.
Here's my big question for you guys: What was your favorite moment from the episode?
And do you feel like, based on the evidence presented in this episode, R +L= J?
During the scene where Barriston was explaining Rhaegar's singing to Daenerys,
they also casually dismissed the threat of Hizdahr.
So, I feel like that's also a kind of warning bell that he is associated with the Sons of the Harpy.
Whether or not he's actually leading them remains to be seen.
Unless they roll out some other big bad, I feel like he is the one calling the shots.
So much great stuff in this episode.
Sansa also gets to have some really interesting times while Littlefinger is gone.
"I'll be a married woman by the time you get back."
The big question with her storyline is: What is she going to do to try and out maneuver Roose Bolton and Ramsay Bolton?
If you're a little confused about Littlefinger's grand scheme here,
in the last episode, he was talking to Roose Bolton about forming an alliance against King's Landing.
But now, in the crypts, he was talking to Sansa about forming an alliance with Stannis
who is going to try to get rid of Roose Bolton.
Add to that, that Cersei is calling him to King's Landing. So Cersei still thinks of him as an ally.
So right now, Littlefinger has like a giant list of opponents that he is all trying to form alliances with at the same time.
Because the show is trying to present Stannis as a hero, I feel like he's the one you would want to back.
The good guys don't always win on Game of Thrones, so it remains to be seen. You can let me know, you know -
Which group do you think is gonna walk away from that big fight?
Do you think that Roose Bolton is gonna be left standing? Or do you think that Stannis is gonna steam roll him?
King's Landing has it's own internal problems. It's not going anywhere anytime soon.
Nobody is marching on King's Landing before the end of the season.
Just a quick reminder on the giveaway: I'm going to announce the winner of that during the Q&A tomorrow,
so just look out for that.
In the mean time, you can click here to learn all about the Sand Snakes and you can click here for last week's episode.
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody, let's high five! I'll see you guys tomorrow.